ROBERT MUELLER.
THERE WORKING FOR ROBERT MUELLER
AND YOU SHOULD KNOW THAT.
KIM STRASSEL JOINS US TONIGHT.
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
BEFORE WE GET INTO WHAT WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT, THERE WAS
NEWS TODAY FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION IS REACHING ITS
FINAL STAGE.
DO YOU THINK THAT'S TRUE, AND
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN EXACTLY?
>> I HOPE SO, TUCKER.
TWO YEARS OF THIS IS TWO YEARS
TOO LONG.
WE NEED SOME ANSWERS AND IT
NEEDS TO HAPPEN SOON.
THIS COULD BE THE BEST AND THAT
HAPPENS IN THE COUNTRY IN A VERY
LONG TIME.
IF IT IS INDEED FINISHING UP.
>> Tucker: WELL, WHAT A
DISTRACTION FROM A LOT OF
IMPORTANT THINGS THAT ARE
HAPPENING.
AS SOMEONE WHO COVERS THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE WORLD FOR A
LIVING, US SOME PERSPECTIVE.
LATE MIDDLE-AGED GUY, NO HISTORY
OF VIOLENCE, NO PASSPORT, NO
FIREARMS IN THE HOME.
UNDER INVESTIGATION FOR OVER A
YEAR.
EMAILS AND TEXTS ALREADY IN THE
POSITION OF THE PROSECUTOR.
WOULD YOU SEND DOZENS OF ARMED
MEN TO ARREST HIM?
IS THAT NORMAL?
>> NO, OF COURSE NOT.
OF COURSE NOT.
OF COURSE IT'S NOT NORMAL.
AS YOU SAY, THE STANDARD
OPERATING PROCEDURES HERE WOULD
BE TO CALL HIS LAWYER AND ASKED
HIM TO SURRENDER.
I THINK IT GETS TO THE OTHER
POINT OF YOUR OPENING AS WELL.
MR. MUELLER UNFORTUNATELY DOES
NOT ANSWER TO ANYONE.
AS A RESULT, WE CAN BRING UP
THESE TOPICS.
YOU CAN CALL AND ASK THE
QUESTION WHY DO YOU DO IT?
HE DOESN'T HAVE TO ANSWER IT.
HE DOESN'T HAVE TO ANSWER TO
ANYBODY IN THE END.
THAT IS ONE OF THE REASONS THAT
WE SHOULD HOPE THAT ALL THIS IS
ENDING.
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
LIST OF PEOPLE HE'S GONE AFTER
AND THE CRIMES FOR WHICH THEY'VE
BEEN GONE AFTER.
NEARLY ALL OF THEM CRIMES THAT
HE CLAIMS THEY HAVE COMMITTED
AFTER HE WAS APPOINTED AS
SPECIAL COUNSEL.
NOT ANY FOR THE TIME.
MACKEY WAS ACTUALLY ASKED TO
INVESTIGATE, AT LEAST NOT IN
AMERICA.
>> Tucker: IS A CONSTITUTIONAL
QUESTION, HOW IN A DEMOCRATIC
REPUBLIC AND YOU HAVE SOMEONE IS
ACCOUNTABLE TO NO ELECTED
PERSON, WHO WAS ACCOUNTABLE TO
NO VOTERS.
I THOUGHT ALL POWER AND THE
GOVERNMENT EMANATES FROM VOTERS.
BUT MUELLER STANDS APART.
HOW CAN THIS BE CONSTITUTIONALLY
ALLOWED?
>> WHILE, LEGAL SCHOLARS HAVE
HAD A LOT OF PROBLEMS WITH THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL LAW FOR A LONG
TIME, PARTLY ON REASONS THAT YOU
JUST MENTIONED AND ALSO ON
ACCOUNTABILITY QUESTIONS.
LOOK, IN THEORY, HE CAN BE
FIRED, OKAY?
WHAT WE BOTH UNDERSTAND IS THAT
POLITICALLY CAN'T BE FIRED
BECAUSE OF THE BROUHAHA THAT
WOULD COME UP WITH ANY WORK TO
ACTUALLY TELL HIM TO STEP DOWN.
>> Tucker: SO WHY DOESN'T --
APART FROM WHAT YOU THINK OF
TRUMP OR MAYBE YOU BELIEVE TRUMP
IS A SECRET AGENT WORKING FOR
VLADIMIR PUTIN, BUT EVEN IF YOU
BELIEVE THAT, WHY WOULDN'T --
AND YOU ARE LIBERAL, WHY
WOULDN'T YOU BE VERY WORRIED
ABOUT A PROSECUTOR WHO IS
OPERATING WHOLLY OUTSIDE THE
SYSTEM AND ACCOUNTABLE TO
NOBODY?
IF YOU REALLY CARED ABOUT
DEMOCRACY, THAT WOULD TERRIFY
YOU, WOULDN'T IT?
>> WE HAVE SEEN THE LEFT CHANGE
THEIR VIEW ON ALL KINDS OF
THINGS, TUCKER.
THIS IS THE PARTY THAT AT
ONE POINT CARED ABOUT ABUSE OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT TACTICS.
THEY CARED ABOUT THE THINGS YOU
JUST MENTIONED, ACCOUNTABILITY,
MAKING SURE THAT THERE WAS
ACCOUNTABILITY AND DEMOCRACY AND
THAT SOMEONE HAD TO ANSWER TO
SOMEONE ELSE.
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO
DONALD TRUMP, THEY ARE QUITE
HAPPY TO THROW ALL OF THAT ON
THE OTHER SIDE.
IT'S A VERY FRUSTRATING TO
PEOPLE LIKE ME WHO'D BEEN TRYING
TO WRITE ABOUT MR. MUELLER'S
PROBE IN AN OBJECTIVE WAY AND
LOOK AT THE EVIDENCE OUT THERE
IN AN OBJECTIVE WAY AND SAY
LOOK, WOULD ANYBODY LIKE TO SEE
WHAT HAPPENED TO CARTER PAGE
HAPPEN TO ANYBODY ELSE ON THE
BASIS OF THE OPPOSITION RESEARCH
THEY USED?
THE DEMOCRATS SHOULD BE VERY
WORRIED THAT A FUTURE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT MIGHT DO THIS TO ONE
OF THEIR CANDIDATES, AND NO ONE
SHOULD WANT THAT.
>> Tucker: I WILL DEFEND THAT